this nasty little fungus has jumped from
the screen into your life
you've just eaten the deadly parasite
spores from The Last of Us
but where would you find this fungus
how do its spores turn living things
into zombies
and how could this fungus improve your
love life
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you ate the cordyceps from The
Last of Us
the cordyceps fungus has taken over the
world in the popular game and now TV
show The Last of Us
but how much of this drama is based on
reality
well more than you think in South
America these parasitic spores have
decimated populations of ants beetles
and spiders
in ants the cordyceps releases a
neuromodulator a chemical cocktail that
keeps the brain healthy while the body
hideously transforms
like in the show the fungus Sprouts a
fruiting body that pops out of the
insect's mouth the ants lose control of
themselves and viciously bite anything
in their way
over time the fungus explodes out of the
ant's body raining down spores and Death
on the other ants nearby and then the
cycle begins again
but could this deadly zombie fungus ever
jump from insects to humans
in the show and in the video game the
fungal infestation causes a human's body
and brain to mutate
the victims become bloodthirsty
creatures the infected
some of the most terrifying of the
infected are the clickers who are more
fungus than human
these terrifying monsters roam the
streets using their echolocation
abilities to hunt down fresh meat like
you
as the humans die they find a secluded
area to release spores back into the
world just like infected ants do in real
life
but ants aren't the only species to
suffer from fungi like cordyceps there
are fungal infections in humans that can
lead to deadly consequences too
fungus like candida Ares have emerged as
a growing threat to humanity
this yeast enters the bloodstream and
causes severe infections the fungus
resists drug treatment and sends its
victims to the hospital for long periods
of time
and don't forget ergot this fungal
disease that contaminates rye grain can
spread gangrene in your arms and legs
if you ate this fungus you would feel
like you're on fire and would suffer
intense hallucinations
in The Last of Us Humanity meets its End
by eating products like pancake mix
contaminated by cordyceps
so if you ate the cordyceps fungus would
you zombify like the ants
yeah that would be unlikely
the fungus hasn't adapted to produce the
same reaction in every species Evolution
would need more time to create a strain
of cordyceps that would destroy Humanity
and considering that cordyceps has been
around for millions of years well that
probably won't be happening anytime soon
I mean unless we turn this planet into a
hot house
we'll get to that later
in reality humans have been eating
cordyceps for a long time Chinese
Tibetan and Northern Indian cultures
have used the fungus to treat illnesses
in their traditional medicine
in China they take the fruiting stocks
from Dead Infected insects to treat
fatigue kidney disease and low sex
drives
are you in the mood now
lab testing has shown that eating
cordyceps has positively affected
Animals by treating chronic diseases
like lymphoma and lung cancer
but this stuff isn't cheap it'll cost
you up to eighteen thousand dollars per
kilogram of cordyceps stocks
so how is this safe to eat
well your body generates too much heat
for this zombie fungus to turn you into
a Mindless killer
for now at least
as temperatures rise across the globe
the fungus might one day adapt to cause
the Mayhem you love to watch every week
so if you want to survive like Joel well
you may have to live without pancakes if
you call that living
but what if the cordyceps did wipe out
Humanity
what if the Last of Us happened in real
life
well stay right here because
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]